the strand survived through my
grandfather and my dad's very hard work
and their passion for this and then the
city comes just with one vote and takes
a piece of it they just want to put a
bureaucratic noose around me we're just
asking to be left alone The Strand is
New York City's last great bookstore a
four-story literary Emporium crammed
with 18 miles of merchandise stuffed
into towering bookcases arranged along
narrow passageways Nancy bass white who
owns both the Strand and the building it
inhabits is fighting to prevent the city
from designating it a historic landmark
she says that the effort to preserve the
building could destroy her business once
a structure is landmark the owner needs
to get permission from the city before
renovating the interior or altering the
facade it would be very difficult to be
commercially nimble or landmarked we'd
have to get approvals through a whole
committee and bureaucracy that do not
know how to run a bookstore and that
does not allow me the flexibility to
change with the changing retail book
environment and to serve our customers
The Strand started at is just one
destination along the world-famous
booksellers row a commercial district
comprised of about 40 second-hand
dealers when Weyden's immigrant
grandfather opened his books tall and
8th Street in 1927 nobody could have
predicted that one day would be the
district's sole survivor widen sense of
outrage that the city wants to
compromise her property rights derives
in part from her father and grandfathers
decades of struggle to keep the business
alive the Depression hit so my
grandfather just reverted to living in a
cot in the basement of the of the
bookstore my grandfather and my dad both
worked most of their life six days a
week hardly took vacations and she was
credit my dad saved up all of his money
to buy the building if it's not land
market there is the chance that you can
be like screw it you know what I
realized I want to go and spend the rest
of my life on the beach I'm shutting
down the business I'm selling the
property and it's gonna get renovated
and that's my right believe it is my
right I mean after
three generations of sweat and toll I
mean I should have our say on what we're
going to do so how is it that widens
freedom to do what she wants with her
bookstore can be curtailed by 11
unelected individuals signed into law in
1965 the landmarks Act was challenged as
unconstitutional 13 years later by the
owner of Grand Central Terminal which
sued the city for preventing it from
building a skyscraper on top of the
train station the Supreme Court upheld
the law setting a precedent that in the
dissenting opinion of Justice William
Rehnquist undermined constitutional
protections as Rehnquist wrote the city
had in a literal sense taken substantial
property rights from the company without
offering just compensation as required
by the Fifth Amendment since that ruling
the number of landmark properties in New
York has more than doubled to about
36,000 encompassing more than a quarter
of all the buildings in Manhattan when
the owners of those properties objected
their stories rarely garnered attention
one of the differences is that you're
the strand and you matter so people pay
attention do you feel like this type of
story is playing out on different levels
for property owners or business owners
who might not be as famous as you or in
places as kind of media centric yes I've
been able to get more attention because
of that and more public outcry and I
think that there are other business
owners like me that end up just kind of
getting trapped in this situation
without much of a voice in her
opposition to land marking the Strand
we're just asking to be left alone Wyden
is unknowingly echoing the line of
retired public school librarian Ella sue
dam owner of a Brooklyn farmhouse that
had been in her family since 1722 the
hell are you to tell me what I can do
with my house sue damn told the
Landmarks Commission in 1980
intimidating its members into backing
off the Commission waited until Sudan
was dead nine years later two landmark
her property
most building owners are less successful
in their dealings with the Landmarks
Commission take this property in
Manhattan's Meatpacking District one of
a handful of buildings purchased in the
1940s by Luis maehlman a Russian born
butcher by 2003 his son and grandsons
were planning to cash in by building a
much taller building on the site enter
the Landmarks Commission if the
abilities become part of the Landmark
District this will essentially eliminate
new construction and eliminate the
ability for our family to utilize the
undeveloped air rights the mailman's
lost their fight later that year all
done with your shopping list just for
you Wyden is committed to preserving her
family's legacy
happy holidays thanks for coming she
just objects to the loss of control over
her property you add another component
of government you add bureaucracy you
add committees you add people having
opinions about what we should do inside
the store as well as outside the store
our family's been a great steward two
years ago there was a massive sewer fire
and we restored the windows to the prior
look and we restored the granite pillars
to the way it originally had been I want
to continue the strand forever that's my
legacy and my goal in life but Kenna
bricks-and-mortar bookstore really
survived forever in 1969 at a time when
the Strand was thriving Weyden's father
Fred Bass
told a New York Times reporter that
obsolescence would come eventually
someday he said readers will have a
telephone with a screen and you'll be
able to dial a book readers will have
instant contact with thousands of books
then I'll go into the antique yes you
know he wasn't wrong can you imagine a
time when the Strand will come and go
and you'll be selling antiques or you'll
be selling them yoga pants and stuff
I hope not I'd like to have a shot at a
fourth generation of my kids running the
store and continuing New York City needs
unusual places like the Strand with 91
years of history
for the city to get out of its way so it
can continue do you think you're gonna
win your fight I've been told that
nobody wins with landmarks but I want to
fight them because it's just so wrong
and so unjust and and so unfair and we
can't let them keep running over
everybody in their way
[Music]